Ten years after Revenge of the Sith, Obi-Wan
Kenobi is readying a rematch with Darth Vader.
"Hello there."
It's a good time to be a "Star Wars" fan.
After the one-two punch of "The Mandalorian"
Seasons 1 and 2, followed by "The Book of
Boba Fett," Disney isn't letting up.
It's only a short wait until May 25th, the
day "Obi-Wan Kenobi" lands on Disney+, with
the lead role reprised once more by Ewan McGregor.
He will be joined by his former castmate Hayden
Christensen, who returns as Anakin Skywalker,
now known as Darth Vader.
Even more "Star Wars: Episode III – Revenge
of the Sith" alums are along for the ride
as Joel Edgerton and Bonnie Piesse return
to their roles as Owen and Beru Lars, Luke
Skywalker's uncle and aunt.
It even appears Jimmy Smits may return as
the Senator from Alderaan, Bail Organa.
In terms of new faces, comedian and "Eternals"
star Kumail Nanjiani is on board in a still-unknown
role.
"Game of Thrones" alumna Indira Varma and
Moses Ingram of "The Queen's Gambit" fame
had similarly secretive roles until the new
teaser trailer dropped on March 9th.
The sneak peek at the original series reveals
Varma is playing an Imperial officer, and
Ingram will be playing the role of Reva, an
Imperial Inquisitor.
With so many characters from the prequel trilogy
making their return amidst so many new faces,
many fans have wondered when, exactly, "Obi-Wan
Kenobi" takes place and how it fits into the
larger "Star Wars" timeline.
As it turns out, those questions have quite
intriguing answers.
Despite so much about the show being shrouded
in Sith-like secrecy, we still know a lot
about where "Obi-Wan Kenobi" fits into the
history of "Star Wars."
"That's good news."
"Obi-Wan Kenobi" will take place about 10
years after the rise of the Empire in "Revenge
of the Sith," as confirmed by a tweet from
the official "Star Wars" Twitter account from
December 2020.
To date, the Disney+ "Star Wars" shows have
primarily focused on the post-Imperial era.
Both "The Mandalorian" and "The Book of Boba
Fett" are set in the years after the death
of Emperor Palpatine in "Star Wars: Episode
VI – Return of the Jedi," so it will be
fascinating to finally see a story that takes
place during the height of Imperial power.
Based on what we've seen in trailers and from
casting announcements, "Obi-Wan Kenobi" will
follow its titular character as he watches
over a young Luke Skywalker (and perhaps a
young Leia) from afar.
It appears the Clone Wars general is being
pursued by Imperial forces all the while,
including several red-lightsaber toting figures
who appear to be Imperial Inquisitors.
These are Force-sensitive hunters tasked with
exterminating the last of the Jedi Order,
led by the former Jedi known now as the Grand
Inquisitor.
It appears the Empire is still busy hunting
down those who managed to save themselves
after Order 66 and will stop at nothing to
purge the galaxy of them.
Obi-Wan is sure to be a major target in their
campaign, especially since Hayden Christensen
is slated to return as Darth Vader.
Something tells us he's not going to let his
former master slip off into the twin sunsets
of Tatooine so easily.
"I'm getting too old for this sort of thing."
The final act of "Revenge of the Sith" ends
with Obi-Wan Kenobi witnessing the birth of
Padmé Amidala's newborn twins, Luke and Leia.
After Padmé dies in childbirth, a decision
is made to separate the twins and keep them
in hiding.
Senator Organa and his wife become the adoptive
parents of Leia, who will grow up on Alderaan.
Meanwhile, Luke is destined to grow up on
Tatooine, where Ewan McGregor's Obi-Wan Kenobi
leaves him in the care of Owen and Beru Lars.
"Star Wars: Episode IV – A New Hope" takes
place 19 years after "Revenge of the Sith,"
which means Luke and Leia are also 19 years
old when the original "Star Wars" trilogy
kicks off.
This puts Disney+ limited series "Obi-Wan
Kenobi" almost smack in the middle of the
two films in regard to the "Star Wars" timeline.
This is seemingly confirmed by the brief shot
of what appears to be a young Luke, who looks
to be nine or 10 years old, in the new teaser
trailer.
Raised by Uncle Owen and Aunt Beru, Luke is
seen through Obi-Wan's futuristic binoculars
living on their moisture farm and pretending
to podrace.
This may be a deliberate callback to "Star
Wars: Episode I – The Phantom Menace," in
which a much younger Obi-Wan meets a much
younger Anakin, also a podracer, on that same
sandy planet.
Being set nine years before "A New Hope" also
means that "Obi-Wan Kenobi" happens around
the time of the events of "Solo: A Star Wars
Story," which follows a young Han Solo, Lando
Calrissian, and Chewbacca.
It's unlikely that Obi-Wan will cross paths
with any of those characters, both because
none of the "Solo" actors have been cast in
"Obi-Wan Kenobi" and because the Jedi-in-hiding
doesn't meet Han Solo until the cantina scene
in "A New Hope."
Still, it's thrilling for fans to finally
see the years between the prequels and the
original trilogy explored in such depth.
"Always on the move.”
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.